if they thought tear gas would keep
people off the streets of Marseille they
were wrong
by early evening the crowds were back
but this time the police weren't taking
any chances
after looters had wreaked havoc they
were determined to clear the streets
in reinforced numbers officers Unleashed
smoke bombs
tear gas and rubber bullets arresting
people as they went
but the crowds were defiant some
taunting the police in reply
What's Happening Here is a game of cat
and mouse basically the police are
dispersing
the crowds and then they're reforming
they're pushing them into a new place
and then it's happening all over again
on the sideline some lit fires burning
whatever they could find
all ripped up road signs as makeshift
weapons
while many seem motivated just to make
trouble others had come with a message
like Hamza the police in French is uh
Hamza says this violence is the backlash
of years of police racism and
discrimination
there's lots of looting here in France
because what do they do they shoot at us
and we loot for Revenge he tells me
scenes like this won't help build
relations
but neither will this video showing
rioter's lutic four cars
the shooting of a teenager sparked this
unrest now deep-seated divisions
continue to fuel it
Siobhan Robbins Sky News Marseille